[Music]
as part of our continuing coverage of
the pandemics effect on families
our special series school matters takes
a comprehensive look
at the debates over how schools are
returning in the fall
through september we'll make sense of
the debates unfolding over reopening
schools safely and
remote learning starting with expanded
coverage in monday's eight o'clock
hour we'll hear from parents students
educators and medical experts
as well as some big names names rather
who have long advocated for the
importance of education
as part of our special coverage we'll be
joined live by a music legend
who's made it her mission to get more
books into the hands of children
this is dolly parton and education is so
important to me
that i started my own imagination
library where we give books to children
from the time
they are born once a month until they
start school so they can learn to read
everybody needs to be educated watch for
me on cbs this morning we'll talk about
it
we look forward to that it's a fabulous
program you can watch our school matters
series beginning monday
at eight a.m we'd also like to hear from
you students and
parents email your questions to
coronavirus
at cbsnews.com